in 2001 larry sanger co-founded
wikipedia he left the country
company some years ago but in the years
since wikipedia
has gone on to become the world's single
most important source
of history of information about the
world
and so it's a problem that we ought to
pay attention to when larry sanger
himself says
that wikipedia is no longer a reliable
source of honest information
he says the editors of wikipedia use
highly politicized sources
and block dissenting news outlets from
contributing
and once again that's a problem for all
of us larry sanger joins us tonight
larry singer thanks so much for coming
on this is
one of those things that a lot of people
a lot of us who use wikipedia have
noticed
wait a second you know i know some facts
that are somehow not in this entry
or they're playing up something that
doesn't seem to be true or this is
highly politicized
you see the bigger picture here what do
you think is going on
well it's complicated for one thing
wikipedia allows anonymous contribution
and that means that
because it's one of the most uh popular
sources of information online there's
a natural incentive for
governments and corporations spies even
criminal operations to basically learn
how to play the wikipedia game
so it's it's opaque to me now how it
really works
and what results is basically
establishment views
are the ones that you find pushed and
they have
they've completely abandoned the neutral
point of view
that's a problem because i in my view
wikipedia
shapes this country's understanding of
the world it is the primary source of
information for a lot of people i would
probably say most people actually
about history so we need to fix this how
do you think that we would do that
well i thanks for asking that
i don't know that there is a way to
fix wikipedia within wikipedia
um it's an institutionally conservative
place what i want to see
actually is a new basically
uh knowledge comments a network of all
the encyclopedia articles
in the world collected together and made
easily
searchable you you understand how the
blogosphere
works right so there's a standard that
is used
and that makes it possible to collect
blog
blogs and blog articles from all over
the place
i want the same thing to happen but with
with
uh encyclopedia articles and if we did
that then we wouldn't no longer have to
depend
on wikipedia and we'd have
especially if we coupled that with a
rating system
then we would be able to or multiple
rating systems actually
um that would enable us to find the best
articles from our own point of view
on every subject and again we would then
be free of wikipedia
it must kill you as one of the people
who founded wikipedia which has become
this
the central part of our of our culture
of our intellectual life
whereas it is to say to watch what's
happened to it how do you feel about
that
i'm sorry how do i feel about what
your role in creating this thing that
misleads the country
i i'm embarrassed to be quite honest and
i've said so for a long time
um i i've been a leading critic of
wikipedia for
over a decade now and um
i've been trying various things to to
try to
improve on it and i'm sorry to all the
people whose reputations have been
sullied
by um by what i got started
20 years ago yeah
well google has helped a lot by
promoting wikipedia which it assiduously
does
larry singer i appreciate you're coming
on tonight uh you don't need to atone
here right but i appreciate your honesty
thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else